لأننا لا نعرف من أين
جاء الفيروس التاجي الجديد ، لكن
نظريات المؤامرة تملأ الفراغ
الذي أخبرك أن trichomes
تحاول تسليح هذا الشيء ،
مضيف البرنامج الحواري المحافظ Rush Limbaugh بدون
دليل يشير إلى أن مختبر الأسلحة البيولوجية الصيني
هو المسؤول  غرد مسؤول صيني على
تويتر ، قد يكون الجيش الأمريكي هو من جلب
الوباء إلى ووهان ، لكن للعثور على
المصدر الحقيقي لهذا الوباء ، من الأفضل
ترك الأمر للعلم ، وقد تحدثت سي إن إن إلى
نصف دزينة من صيادي الفيروسات الذين
يقولون الآن أي شخص يدعي أنهم يعرفون  يُخمن
المصدر الدقيق لفيروس كورونا الجديد
هل جاء من الخفافيش على
الأرجح أن الباحثين الصينيين قد
قرروا بالفعل أن فيروس كورونا متطابق بنسبة 96٪
على مستوى الجينوم بأكمله مع
فيروس كورونا الخفافيش 27 علماء الصحة العامة
من جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة
والعالم
كتب هذا  رسالة في مجلة لانسيت
تدين نظريات المؤامرة
وتستشهد بالأدلة العلمية بما في ذلك
المراكز الأمريكية لمكافحة الأمراض التي
تدعم نظرية ر  استنتج قبعة بأغلبية ساحقة
أن فيروس كورونا
نشأ في الحياة البرية كما هو الحال مع العديد
من مسببات الأمراض الناشئة الأخرى ، القاسم المشترك
هو الحياة البرية.هذه الكائنات الممرضة
تنبثق من الحياة البرية ، أحد هؤلاء
العلماء هو أحد أبرز
الباحثين عن الفيروسات في العالم بيتر
جاك لأننا كنا كذلك  عند القيام بهذا
العمل في الصين لمدة عشر سنوات ، لدينا
سلسلة كاملة من التسلسلات الجينية
للفيروسات التي وجدناها مع زملائنا ،
لذلك عندما أصيبوا بفيروس جديد في الأشخاص
بسبب ثاني أكسيد الكربون في منتصف التسعينيات ، يمكنهم
مقارنته بما رأوه.  في الخفافيش ،
فأنت على الفور
يتعلق الأمر بفيروس الأصل ولأنه يحتوي
على معدل مقارنة بنسبة 96٪ لما كان موجودًا
بالفعل في الخفافيش ، ولهذا السبب
تقول إنه من المحتمل جدًا أن هذا قد
أتى من خفاش على الرغم من أننا لا  تعرف
على مصدر هذه السلالة في الواقع ،
نحن على ثقة تامة من أن
أصل Kobe 19 في الخفافيش ،
ولا نعرف بالضبط من أين نشأت ،
لذلك هذا ما نحتاج إلى القيام به الآن هو
اكتشاف جيني  سيتتبع باحثو القصة الواقعية
الفيروس الذي
يقتل الآلاف - لم يتم أسره بعد
في البرية إلى حيوان
محتمل أصبح وسيلة الانتقال لـ
Covet 19 نعم ، كان من الممكن أن
ينتقل الفيروس مباشرة من الخلف إلى الإنسان
ولكن على الأرجح يقول - ik it  كانت الخفافيش
تصيب الحيوانات المستزرعة التي
أحضرتها الحيوانات إلى السوق على قيد الحياة واحتفظت بها مع
الناس في واحدة من أكثر
الحاضنات مثالية للعدوى الفيروسية
، السوق الصيني الرطب ،
يعيش هذا التنوع الهائل من الحيوانات في أقفاص
فوق بعضها البعض ، وأنت تعرف
كومة الماعز التي  تم
سحبها وإلقائها على الأرض لأنك
تريد أن تسأل الأكشاك التي تنزلق فيها على
البراز والدم ، فهذه
أماكن مثالية لانتشار الفيروسات ، ليس فقط
لأن الناس يعملون هناك ، فالناس
يأتون لشراء الحيوانات التي يقومون
بتقطيعها  هم أمامك
والأطفال يلعبون هناك ، تعرف أن العائلات
تعيش هناك تقريبًا ، يُدعى
البروفيسور أندرو
كننغهام الذي ينتشر حيوانيًا مع جمعية علم الحيوان
لقد درسها ty of London لعقود من الزمان ، فإن
أسواق الحيوانات الحية هذه
هي بالتأكيد طريقة جيدة جدًا ، وإذا
كنت ترغب في محاولة انتقال الفيروس
إلى الأشخاص من الحياة البرية ،
فهم عرضة للإصابة بالفيروسات
أو مسببات الأمراض الأخرى من البيئة
أو  من الحيوانات الأخرى التي لن
يتواصلوا معها بشكل طبيعي
مرة أخرى بسبب إجهادهم ومن ثم
يمكن أن يصبحوا مصانع للفيروسات وهم
على اتصال وثيق بالبشر
في الأسواق ويتم ذبحهم في
الأسواق ومن قبل الأشخاص في
ظروف غير صحية نسبيًا يشير باحثون آخرون
إلى تقارير واردة من الصين تفيد بأن بعض
الحالات المبكرة لم تكن
مرتبطة بالسوق الرطب ، ثم هناك
هذه النظرية التي دحضت هذه الورقة البحثية
من باحثين صينيين تقول
إنه من المعقول أن يكون الفيروس قد تسرب عن
طريق الخطأ من واحدة من اثنتين.  قال
أحد المؤلفين لصحيفة The
Wal  l ستريت جورنال ، تم سحب الصحيفة
لأنها لم تكن مدعومة
بأدلة مباشرة صائدي فيروسات متمرسين
- يقول IK و Cunningham أن
النظرية هي أن الناس لا يبقيون الخفافيش في
الرأسمالية
هراءًا نظيفًا لسنا بحاجة إلى استدعاء
نظريات المؤامرة إنها مجرد أساسية
تسببت التوترات البيولوجية بين الولايات المتحدة
والصين بشأن أصول الفيروس
والاتهامات بالتضليل من كلا
الجانبين في إبطاء عمل
صيادي الفيروسات الذين تعتمد عليهم نفس
قيود السفر التي
شلت العالم المثير للقلق لأنه
دون معرفة من أين جاء.
لا تزال هناك فرصة لأن الأنواع الأصلية المضيفة
هي التي تنشرها إذا كان هناك
ما يسمى بالمضيف الوسيط وهو حيوان
دخل فيه فيروس الخفافيش ثم
سمح له بالوصول إلى الأشخاص ،
فربما لا يزال الفيروس موجودًا في ذلك المضيف
وهناك المئات  الآلاف من هذه الحيوانات
في المزارع وربما الفيروس لا يزال
موجودًا ، لذا حتى لو تخلصنا من
تفشي المرض ، فلا تزال هناك فرصة لهذا
الفيروس.  d ثم يعاود الظهور ونحتاج
إلى إيجاد ذلك بسرعة